United States Park Police shot and killed
an unarmed 25-year-old man during a traffic stop
in Fairfax County.
There are so many questions in this case.
One of the only things we know
for certain is that a Northern Virginia
family is now left without a son.
[gunshots]
It is over 31 million seconds ago that this happened.
It's just a number. Sounds so far away or so distant.
But at the same time, the memory is so alive,
I can feel the shots.
The last time I checked,
we live in the United States of America
and it is not appropriate to not give any information
for an entire year
when someone's life is taken, by anyone.
We were notified that there was a shootout.
We were told to go to the Fairfax hospital.
They said that his body was evidence
and that he was under arrest,
which to this day we have no idea
why and no one has explained that to us.
Bijan was the pride that I carried
in my heart.
I think everywhere we go now,
it's a little bit quieter and a little less fun.
Bijan was hit from behind by an Uber driver while he was on the George Washington Memorial Parkway.
From what we know, either the Uber driver
or the passenger or both called 911
which was rerouted, and the Park
Police picked it up and they found him
minutes later and actually started
pursuing him then.
Before I saw this video, I thought maybe
one guy panicked and just fired off
his gun and it just kept going off.
But that's not what happened.
He was stopped three times.
Every single instance of it they're aggressively approaching him with their guns drawn.
I think in that moment,
when someone walked out of their vehicle
and pointed a gun at his head and
tried to yank his door open,
that he was in fear for his life, rightfully so.
As far as driving away from the officers,
if anyone walked up to my car with their
gun drawn, civilian or law enforcement officer,
after a minor traffic violation,
I would be freaking out.
The third time that Bijan stopped at the
corner of Fort Hunt and Alexandria Avenue,
the Park Police drove in front of
his car and they were perpendicular to him.
The two officers jumped out of their cars
and approached directly to his vehicle
and he slowly, I guess, took his foot off the brake
and it looked like he was moving around the officers.
[gunshots]
Clearly my brother was unconscious
careening into a ditch and someone felt the need
to take his gun back out,
walk up to his window,
as he was unconscious, going into a ditch
and shoot him in the head again.
[gunshots]
We want answers for every single one of
those nine shots fired at him,
particularly the last two, directly at
his driver's side window, execution-style.
There's nothing in the tape that in any way,
shape or form, suggests that he was a threat.
He wasn't driving particularly fast.
He did stop,
unfortunately, he kept on driving on
a few occasions as well
but he's not veering towards the officers.
In the U.S., police shoot to kill, right?
They're not shooting to wound
anyone.
It really adds insult to the family
who has not only lost their loved one
but in a way that desecrates the body
and the person that they loved.
We have someone that has been
essentially executed by the Park Police.
We don't know who did it,
the name has not been released
and no answers have been given.
Our treatment in the hospital was
extremely egregious
and it was extremely uncomfortable for all of us.
They set up all these weird rules for us
while we were at the hospital, the Park Police.
There were two Park Police officers at a time
outside of his door.
The rule was that one person could go in between
me, my husband and my parents,
at a time, at the top of every hour for 10 minutes.
If we were late by one minute, if they were
changing any dressings or anything like that,
the nurses, we would lose like a couple of minutes.
We could not touch him at all;
no body part, nowhere, under any circumstances.
He was in a coma,
his body was decaying.
At some point, he would either have a heart attack,
which we didn't want him to die twice,
that just seemed cruel,
or his organs would start shutting down
which is what was happening.
November 17, Bijan was shot.
And November 27, ten days later,
Bijan left this world.
My son, Bijan, was a manifestation
of American dream.
Our parents were extremely supportive
and they really were big on making sure
that we understood our roots of being
Iranian but also being
extremely proud and patriotic and
understanding our American side too.
He was a die-hard football lover.
While he was in college, he was in fraternity
and his fellow brothers, they called him,
"Brother of the Year."
Bij was the loudest person in the room.
He had this presence that was like larger than life.
He was very giggly, he was very witty.
When something like this happens, your whole world that you build, falls apart.
Everything you believe in falls apart.
Living is a challenge now.
It's a whole lot more difficult than dying.
You wake up and try to make some sense out of this,
which I still haven't been able to make
any sense out of it.
When you see Park Police,
you should not feel threatened.
And unfortunately, what the Park Police
has done, not just by murdering Bijan,
but also by their cover up and their
silence, has actually left many people
with a fear of the Park Police rather
than seeing them as their protectors.
There is, in my opinion, absolutely no
justification for taking someone's life
over a traffic incident, ever,
under any circumstance.
There's an over-representation of, especially men, black men who are impacted by police killings.
Eric Garner was killed over four years ago,
and just now the officer who's responsible
for putting him in a chokehold is only being
considered for disciplinary actions.
Not enough people are outraged about it
and people don't become outraged about it
until it happens to someone that they
care about, and that's a real problem.
We want names.
We want justice.
We are Bijan.
He loved the Patriots, he was 25-years-old,
he just graduated from undergraduate
he was part of a fraternity.
A lot of the things we know about Bijan are things we know
about people that we know and
love, as well.
And that's true of almost all of the
people impacted by these killings, to be clear.
They're important members of their community,
they're loved by their family
and nobody sees it coming and one
day they're just not there.
This cannot stand.
There needs to be justice for Bijan
and there needs to be measures to make sure that this never, ever, ever happens again.
We want police to wear body cameras and dash cameras.
We want answers.
We want justice for Bijan.
you